on this episode and I'm gonna say it the
legendary Ken aletta stops by everybody
it's gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 287 of the askgaryvee show I'm
very very excited for this episode not
only is this gentleman my neighbor in
two separate locations but more
importantly he's somebody who I've
admired from afar pretty much as soon as
I started realizing there was business
content in the world and then he
embarked on a book that came out
recently that went very deep into into
the world of advertising and the stuff I
was doing with vaynermedia and then Beth
Comstock the former CMO and then former
chair you know big one of the great big
executives in corporate world somebody I
admire very much texted me one day and
said hey I want you to speak to Ken
aletta he's writing a new book about the
industry and literally it was a massive
highlight for me and so sir thank you so
much for being on the show and so let's
do this because I think the amazing part
of this show and the audience is the
dynamics of how many different kinds of
demos watch the show I'd love to get
before we get into the new book I'd love
to get a two-minute three-minute you
know bio tell us about your career
because I've been watching a bunch of
documentaries and you keep popping up
which makes me laugh and you look the
same
Jenny left to black hair instead of gray
hair but the same face I started I had a
graduate degree in political science and
thought I'd work in government or
something like that and I went to work
for a guy named Howard Samuels who was
who invented baggies in the plastic
clotheslines businessman
it was upstate industrialists he was
running for governor with my help he
lost so I was I was I also work with
Bobby Kennedy's 1968 presidential camp
well that's pie's a low-level yeah
that must have been inspiring and then
devastating both and then I I went to
journalism and wrote starting with
freelance than The Village Voice and New
York magazine both when Murdoch took
over did a hostile takeover a group of
us quit rather than as a protest rather
than work for him I think it was that
that was 77 in the winter of 77 was that
his first play in the States
no his is firstly he bought the New York
Post in 76 and promised it would stay a
liberal newspaper and then obviously
reneged on right and he had bought the
San Antonio newspaper as well but he had
done hostile takeovers in the UK and in
Australia before so he had a bad
reputation but obviously an interesting
businessman sure and then I was I went
to work both The New Yorker and writing
column for The Daily News and did TV on
wcbs-tv political commentary and have
written for The New Yorker since 77 and
have since written 12 books 12 this is
my 12th book and was the first book you
wrote it's called the streets were paved
with gold okay and it was about what
happened to New York City fiscally not
only a physical crisis but the flight of
the middle class the working class the
race you know polarization and I'm aware
of that book how did it do early on from
a successful standpoint it was not a
best-seller as some of the other books
were but it's a book I'm proud of it was
did it put you on the map from a quality
standpoint in the circles you cared
about well actually you know part of it
some of it ran in the New York magazine
this is before the New Yorker mm-hmm in
like 75 and I did a piece should the
people who hit budget deficits in New
York City
like the mayor of New York both Lindsay
and being the governor governor
Rockefeller a Walter Wriston the head of
Citibank some of the union leaders did
they commit fraud right there for a
crime and Milton Glaser was the name you
probably know the great art direct
course of
New York magazine I said this is the
investigative piece I've done and Milton
right in front of clay Felker the editor
of New York magazine
true what he thought the cover should be
and it was it was the mayor of New York
behind bars
the governor behind bars the bankers
behind bars the labor leaders behind
bars and the headline was should these
people go to jail
and I said oh my god they've just made
this piece come alive I was writing a
serious investigative piece but but he
just crystallized why people would be
drawn in and want to read that so that
was a big piece that was fun yeah
and then I did you know just the over
the years of a number of it was the most
successful book he wrote of the 12 I
think were two commercially most
successful late they got up to number
six on the bestseller New York Times
bestseller lists were the first was
greeting lawyer on Wall Street and that
was about the fall Lehman Brothers and
the greed in the mid 80s infecting Wall
Street and the next one was in 91 and
was called three blind mice yes how the
TV networks lost their way they were
being disrupted by a new technology
which was Kabletown yes and you see a
lot of parallels to what's going on with
social media and things of that nature
to to that thesis as well like platform
shift of attention totally um I I did a
book was also did well as a seller
called googled yes in 2009 and that was
a book about disruption how Google and
digital war was disrupting the legacy
media world of newspapers and magazines
and music etc and then this current book
is about how the disruption that visited
legacy media was now visiting the
advertising world how did you get to the
new book frenemies ring yeah how do I
get to it what's the subtitle it's
called frenemies the epic disruption of
the ad business parenthesis and
everything else yes and
I said Here I am writing for the New
York or something called the annals of
communication I follow the media
business and and yet I don't follow the
advertising business which funds the
media business and if you want to follow
the old Watergate adage follow the money
should not be following what's happening
with advertising and so that set me off
to everybody and you know it's really
funny and a lot of you know who I am I'm
a character that's uh I'm an unusual
dude I literally genuinely when I
started vaynermedia knew nothing about
the advertising world I'd never watched
Mad Men I didn't know how it was
structured I had no idea that they were
mainly run by publicly traded companies
I'd never heard of the name Martha this
is 2009 right when 34 years old I'm a
businessman but I'm in the wine business
I'm in Silicon Valley investing so I'd
never heard of Martin Sorrell or Omnicom
or publicist I didn't know what a
creative director was I I never heard of
as a matter fact vaynermedia's you would
be blown the first 40 employees of
vaynermedia first of all it's called
vaynermedia and what we did was social
media creative we didn't do any media at
the time I mean I knew I we would number
two the first 40 people hired had zero
days of advertising experience Roger I
hired them because I knew that when I
would have conversations with the one or
two people I meant like three people and
you know couple friends were like you
should hire somebody from an agency I'm
like that makes a whole lot of sense and
I sat down with them in 2009 and 10 and
I'm trying to talk to them about why
we're gonna focus on Twitter and
Facebook and you know look I had already
built a very large wine business
I had already invested in Facebook
Twitter Tumblr I had already had a New
York Times bestselling book I was a
businessman and I was 35 and they would
try to convince me on why I needed to
focus on television commercials
basically everything one of the reasons
I admire and like you so much
is you do two things that I like one you
talk about what's coming but it actually
it's already here and that is a very
important statement and that's where my
attachment is to a lot of what I do the
people think that I'm a
Derrida today this has already happened
Facebook's happened it's not coming and
people for financial short-term selfish
reasons hold on to the past and they
don't acknowledge the present not the
future and these are you know I speak a
lot publicly Gary B's here he's a
disrupter this first line I'm like I'm
practical I'm unemotionally practical I
want to be historically correct and I
play for that so nonetheless I
interviewed three people they were
completely completely and utterly
incapable of understanding what was
actually happening
and they were holding up the romance of
an award or an ad age article or
arbitrary Nielsen ratings or there was
nothing smart coming out of anybody's
mouth that was senior or emerging in the
ad world and I decided you know what I'm
gonna hire a bunch of kids and I'm gonna
teach them I'm gonna make sure that they
don't know anything about that old world
I'm gonna establish a DNA in a culture
of kindness and curiosity and and really
the currency that I believe in which is
the pulse of the moment and that's what
we did and that's what it's interesting
every time you I've written a lot about
disruption over the years and and every
time you do that and you probe and you
do these interviews you find people in
legacy media who deny the reality of
what is happening to them and they do it
for lots of reasons and one of the
reasons they do it it was Clayton
Christensen of Harvard wrote a great
book several years ago called the
innovators dilemma and entity argues
that if you have an existing business
that is generating money and has a
reasonable stock price the thought that
you're gonna divert money from your
existing business to some digital
upstart and be punished by crazy Wall
Street because of it you don't do it and
you get frozen in place and by the time
you look up your businesses come ken let
me throw you a curve but not a curve
ball let me tell you what I'm fascinated
by I've always believed that I see it
every day I genuinely believe the
majority of the fortune 500 consumer
packaged goods companies in America are
so in trouble
they have no the crafts and the Unilever
Xinhai you know they are unbelievably
intro
because of what's happening with the
Amazon what's happening with television
and OTT and big-box retail they're on
the drug of Walmart and the channel
conflict Wars of the future are gonna be
remarkable
which means Pepsi wants to go direct but
Albertsons and Walmart and Costco won't
let them and meanwhile that's gonna be
the demise that's you're gonna get to
that one next what's fascinating to me
is you're right I've always been able to
pray pray on the fact that people are
held accountable in 90 day windows and
they will never invest and they will
always be CFOs not CEOs how I think
about it that begs the question please
Manoli becomes to yes and says we want
to hire you yes to do yes a big piece of
our yesterday yes what do you say that I
said sure but please let me do what I
want to do and then they say sure that's
why you're here and then systematically
from day two till year six they close in
the reins of what I'm able to do and you
know you know what's funny about me can
you know this a little bit like this is
gonna be unlinked it's like I'm not
hiding I'm telling my clients that I
don't believe in I'm hiding even less
the only reason I'm building vaynermedia
is to buy my clients brands when they go
out of business I'm literally gonna buy
head and shoulders and crackerjacks and
we DS and you know Dove soap like that
is literally why I came into the
industry I don't want to be the next WPP
I don't want to build an agency I wanted
to meet people and build capabilities so
that when the carnage came I would be in
a financial position to pick up these
brands and run them I want to buy the
New York Jets by buying rolls around I'm
wearing to get around to they're gonna
get to that I want to buy rolling rock
for two hundred thirty million dollars
from InBev ABI InBev and then sell it to
Miller Coors for 1.7 billion after I run
it for six years and what do you but
that baby selection what would you do
over those six years running it I would
change that it well liquor let's leave
now because the three-tier system but
let's say it's a let's use a head and
shoulders
I would become disproportionally capable
at Amazon and Shopify and I would not
spend money on television and print and
programmatic digital and I would spend
it on Facebook and
Instagram and original media like
podcasting I would contemporize the
business around nostalgia or legacy
brand and how would you create a direct
relationship with the consumer
by creating one through marketing and
comms which is actually marketing where
they actually are that's the punchline
here right like the way they score the
margin is in television and programmatic
that's why those five holding companies
sell that so wouldn't you discover
instead of me yapping my and
pontificating because that's only one
angle or perspective or purview what was
the aha of the ad world and it is the
askgaryvee show I do have some questions
on LinkedIn Twitter Facebook start
putting in phone numbers today because
this is in my fans always know when I
really respect someone instead of
calling and being super pumped to talk
to me which is always flattering I
really want heavy advertising industry
questions if you're in the ad world this
is the time to put your phone number
please respect that we have tons we've
done 280 shows well do 280 more let's
really focus on the subject matter at
hand because it is a you know the thing
that happens when you're in industry no
matter how much you're cynical to it you
start getting very emotional about them
I've fallen in love and made real
friendships I've real friends at Starcom
and media vest and you know Omnicom
because they're just nice people and
they don't see it they don't see it this
is like religion and politics they
actually don't see it and they don't see
it but again I when you ask the aha
moments that's certainly one of them the
blindness of people and related to that
is the insecurities of people they don't
see audacity they can
how much audacity's in the system well
the there's habits in the system okay
and you can call it or dass city but
people doing the same thing yes run over
again and not being able to get off that
track yes but and yet at the same time
as there's denial of that their business
is fundamentally threatened
there's insecurity they're aware that
they don't have the same pay level to
attract people the way of Facebook and
Google sure does for instance well this
insecurity that the mistrust that the
clients have
for the agencies and there's and there's
insecurity about the math men taking
over from the madman yes um and and
that's one of the reasons they hire a
guy like Michael Casson who's one of the
major characters in my book he gives him
a sense security he can introduce him to
his clients Facebook and Google yes and
Microsoft yes and the agencies etc and I
was just struck by the this kind of
contradiction between the kind of
smugness or comfort level and yet the
insecurity well men are opposites but
that's to me that to me is the
characteristics of the moments before
the incumbent takes a fall I know
there's any question man I mean I'm sure
that was the theme of all every time
you've delved into any industry that's
the exact I mean literally you know I
always think about this when it comes to
business there's two ways to build the
biggest building in town one is to just
build the biggest building in town two
is to spend all your time tearing down
everybody else's building and when I see
behavior number two from a collective I
know it's game over right and so that's
what we're seeing so so okay so that
makes sense but I think that's an
unbelievably common theme that you
probably saw in the TV landscape i man
I do have the recordings of when you
write a book like they about the three
networks not seeing what's happening
with cable do you have the actual
recordings like audio or I record
everything are they your IP or they the
publishers IP they're mine I own I have
you thought about putting them out as a
podcast
Ideker i don't consume anything but I
would listen right now to whoever was
running ABC talking about cable
television with the blind audacity that
she or he did in nineteen when did when
you write that book came out 91 in 95
your project first of all that's
laughable to me to begin with here's why
well five years that makes sense to me
the thought that in 1991 there was still
any debate that cable was disrupting the
big
is exactly kind of how I look at this
look at how many goosebumps I'm getting
look at this it's kind of the way I feel
right now which is how does anybody
debate the Facebook's already and and
social media in the mobile device with
social platforms eaten up all the
content consumption and OTT by the way
the three networks
now obviously Disney owns ABC but as an
individual unit ABC CBS and NBC are
completely out of business
in today's world I mean they're not yet
but they have no place outside of live
sports but here here's what's
interesting about and one of the reasons
I made Les Moonves one of the characters
in my book I I did a chapter where I
said Kent can old media act like new
media and and I use Moonves and and CBS
n arguably Les Moonves is the most
successful modern television yes it have
been last yes quarter century no
question and you look at it and and when
I go back to the book I wrote 91 three
why - yes CBS was 100% reliant as were
the other no yes on one source of
revenue advertising that's right since
then yes the government passed the cable
Act of 1990 two years after my book
which gave them something called
retransmission consent which means the
cable companies had to pay them to run
their programs
CBS last year got a billion dollars just
out of that new revenue in 94 the
government passed
FinCEN regulation changes which allowed
the network's to own and sell programs
becomes another source of revenue but
the third new source of revenue is with
the digital platforms like Netflix
Amazon coming on they decide the
networks that they're gonna sell their
programs over their libraries yeah to
the eye to them that's right and and
arguably that it last year gave 250
million dollars each to Fox 750 million
to CBS yes that's great right yes
but what are they really doing and my
one of the reasons I use the title
frenemy in the book is that Netflix is a
frenemy of course their friend and that
they give me a join 50 million dollars
but what are you doing really when you
do that as old media CBS you're giving
up you're giving up the last year the
touch point is the most important thing
precisely the touch points the game
whoever's closest to the consumer wins
so if I'm a consumer of course I say
don't have to wait any longer to
Thursday night for this program come on
horse hey B I don't have to watch
commercials on the horse we always
showed of course and see I am basically
giving ammunition to my competitor the
distributions been commoditized because
of the internet it's now only about the
IP so okay back to the advertising world
do you have a question let's go let's
actually move on to that and we'll come
back what do you got Eddie oh you're
gonna call somebody yeah very nice no
that's fine that's perfect so while
you're doing that uh but you know I want
to talk about Casa de media link because
I please just phone one other thing yeah
please
the the largest lots of enemies in the
advertising world there's a lot of
frenemies in every business right that's
right
but the biggest friend army I discovered
which goes back to haha moment question
in the advertising world the biggest
front of me is the public the public you
need to sell your ads and to in to buy
products but the but the public
increasingly is armed with tools to
prevent your ass from getting through
particularly on their cell phones that's
right you know be it ad blockers at 8%
of Americans have an ad block that's
right 55 percent according to Nielsen
who record programs on the PBRs
skip the ads that's right we don't want
to be interrupted on a most personal
device matters right time matters can
and there's another one which is the
hidden conversation in that even when
it's not being recorded by the date of
an AdBlocker or the Nielsen rating
there's something that has always been
my ally in business her name is common
sense here's what common sense tells you
I don't give a [ __ ] what data is being
thrown around when a commercial comes on
television for most Americans right now
they go and look at their phone period
end of story there's nobody on earth
there's no report that's being
functioned and funded by somebody else
that's gonna convince me that Americans
don't do that
the end attention is the asset so then
the question for the ad and marketing
community is what replaces that if you
can't get their attention with sales
pitches yep with things that feel like
an interruption that's right what
replaces that
to me they're gonna start looking more
like media companies and less like
advertisers okay
and but then that but but one of the
things that the that I came back at me
when I renounced this question of people
in the marketing in the world in
advertising they would say we're gonna
we're gonna offer you services yep not
sales pitches and because we're gonna be
able to target as well know so much
about you Gary yeah they'll be able to
target as at you and then the question
becomes privacy yeah the more it's a
seesaw the more you target the more
privacy goes down the more privacy goes
up the more targeting ability goes down
sure and that's one of the questions for
the future I don't know the answer to it
here's the here's the best part the best
part I wish I got I wish we had a coffee
before he started there would have been
one question I would have begged you
even if you didn't use it as part of the
book just for our own fodder
you don't want my favorite question to
ask everybody in the advertising world
is have you ever sold anything in your
life have you ever worked retail or have
you ever sold have you actually ever
sold anything in your life because what
the question over a thoughtful dinner
and a bottle of wine and if you have a
fair audience and you're a bunch of
friends and you actually talk it out
what you learn about the question have
you ever sold anything my friend is the
following you have two sides of the camp
in the ad world right now the math kids
and the art kids and they all claim
theirs is it the reality is it's both
50/50 all right
50/50 I know it was 50/50 but it's both
it's gonna be 50/50 and I'll tell you
why I believe that it's the the data is
scaling at a level that matters you can
get in front of people better than ever
to your point it will always seesaw but
they'll be the next thing as attention
shifts like you know Facebook won't hold
it forever either it's you know just
that kind of game Amazon won't hold it
forever they may have 10 15 20 30 years
I don't know seven nine but the art is
the variable of success I can get in
front of everybody I can get in front of
everybody let's use politics as
everybody loves to talk about Cambridge
analytics I can get in front of every
liberal and conservative all day long
all day long but what's the picture in
the video to get done
what I want is the variable I can get in
front of somebody you buy cereal all day
but if I'm representing Cocoa Puffs
do I know what picture what copy what
video to get them to do it here's the
problem they're all talking theory my
friend they're all talking theory do you
know many practitioners are in the
advertising world do you know many
people work at Omnicom publicist and all
these companies have our actual doers
and that to me is the punchline but look
but but doers by doing what you mean
what do you mean by doers who actually
create or you or who have done sales
what I'm not sure we're sure that's the
punchline can like to me my dream you
know I always you know one of the
reasons of a nor has grown is we could
be much bigger you know you made a
comment before we win they're like hey
nice new lot like we're growing you
couldn't imagine if I was willing to
give up 1% of my legacy how big this
company would be if I was willing to
sell programmatic if I was willing to
sell television if I was willing to do
that this would be super over they don't
know how good they have it that I'm not
willing to conform because I want to
look good in the recordings and books
when I'm 96 I'll give up the money short
term long term interests yes so the
answer you know he'll dial but the
answer is anything run a face you nobody
people have opinions on facebook ads in
the ad world and I've never run one look
just genuinely don't know what it looks
like to run an ad you know and you know
they treat an award or a report like
religion neither mapped actual business
me you know Ken no actual business no
practitioner ship and yet they say Alan
it's Gary Vee you're on with Ken Auletta
Alan it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
good how are you good you're on with Ken
where you from what do you do what's
your question I'm from Houston Texas
thank you
so I own a a publication here in we're
obviously trying to expand our
publication into other cities okay so we
have a local niche which reef is about
eighty thousand people a month is it a
print publication it it and what's it
called yeah
it's called the lip the list and what
does it do to our website a list dot
city you go to our website called the
list city
okay and the goal that you can check us
out there so so far we're in two cities
we're in Missouri City we're also in
Sugar Land Texas which are predominantly
the top two producing some would service
so we're working on basically expanding
our publications into other cities
across the country Alan what is they
throw Alan what does the list do well
we're a full marketing company so we do
everything so we offer advertising you
know but that's where our revenue comes
from so with your print marketing we do
digital marketing with your social media
we also help with web marketing so we do
a little bit of everything okay and so
what's the question so the biggest thing
is we're trying to to still up so I'm
just trying to figure out how how we can
scale so we started in two city I want
to use that mold that we have and you
know what's the best way to attract new
new businesses new areas based on kind
of what I've already created from
scratch why do people find it valuable
when I'm looking at the list dot city
right now when those functions are so
available on Facebook and Google and the
attention is there what what have you
found
there's been the rationale of the
businesses in those two cities that have
made them want to pony up money in a
world where they would get a lot more
eyeballs and value
doing those things on Facebook and
Google right um you know obviously we're
you know we're part of both of those so
the biggest thing is is what we found
being being in the publication industry
is the lack of niche publications and I
think when you when you have a niche
that people like that kind of gives them
what well what's your what's your niche
that's local arnisia is going to be more
it's a community based publication so we
do a lot of community content we have
community bloggers we've got you know we
say you're you're replicating the old
local newspaper like the Milburn item in
you know Millburn New Jersey no not like
a newspaper no no we're we we so we
provide a lot of like relevant content
obviously we're not a weekly or daily
newspaper we're not the Chronicle you
know or like the Houston Chronicle here
but it's more of a niche that local
people can can jump on that can help
attract you know local businesses small
mom-and-pop businesses that you know you
need to help me here a little bit
because the pitch is so gray I
understand that you want local
businesses to subsidize your business
that I've gathered right you know you go
to local town if we win the attention of
Albuquerque New Mexico I can get 200 to
800 dollars per restaurant lawyer I get
that what the [ __ ] content are you
producing like what do you what do you
how are you getting the citizens of
Albuquerque to go to the site like what
are they consuming what's the content so
we obviously direct them to our website
we put a nice write-up why you should
join it's free I mean obviously it's
kind of like okay real quick
yeah did you help me I think what I'm
hearing now now I'm I think I understand
for the first time it feels like it's
just a Yellow Pages right like is it
just it's just a directory of sorts no
it's it's a it's a it's actually a
combination of all of that so it's kind
of like a Yelp like it like I mean it
it's obviously that they're able to
review their will to join so that's like
yeah so Alan I think I know what you're
doing tell me if you think I'm right
because if you tell me the truth that
I'm right then I can help you make more
money right perfect I think I think what
you're doing is you're just doing a good
job in sales I think what you're doing
is you're just willing some revenue into
the business because you've created the
list makes sense I understand but it
doesn't have the scale that others do
there's the theoretical niche nature of
the local market and then you and
whoever else are just doing a good
enough job of getting 50 to 800 dollars
per small business and as long as
there's just a little traffic coming to
it they can suck they can justify that
minimal investment true correct cool
here's yeah we get about 30 to 40
thousand impressions a month on our on
our site fair enough
it does pretty well I mean I get it
thirty to forty thousand impressions a
month on a website is like a bad
Facebook post you know like like it's
not a lot but you know what's funny I
love what you're doing let me give you a
great piece of advice hire interns and
people fresh out of school pay them as
little as possible but is but good for
them cuz they said yes that's what they
want they want to learn sales and and
basically finds young sales people that
don't cost you the most amount of money
because your business is relying on
small checks and just build a sales
machine you could pick any market or you
can pick a rabbi per market you can say
who wants to be a leader and Topeka
Kansas and then you can build out like
the actual product you're selling
doesn't need to be that good based on
you know the reality and the reality is
with minimal checks a restaurant in
Albuquerque New Mexico may justify the
$200 based on six visitors it seems like
you're playing the long long long long
long tail I think the vulnerability of
the business is you'd like to sell
something that actually brings value but
at the end of day the market is the
market and if the SMB sees value there's
something there can
the other thing I would do is take a
look at what happened with patch patch
was a local online newspapers in
communities around the country there
were several hundred of them I am
Armstrong was a major investor AOL
bought it right at some point when Tim
Cook over a well I bought the company
yeah which he had started yep and it
floundered it failed
yep and and I would look at Wyatt fair
well I think they failed different what
I like about Alan can is they failed
because their ambition and their STIs
was ahead of the reality of their
business and they had so many costs in
the system Alan can build a very nice
$250,000 a year business eight hundred
thousand even up to $800,000 b-but Alan
look look man I love you and I want to
bring you value you know the product you
have isn't unbelievably valuable what I
like about your potential is you could
be in the long long long long long tail
of sales that's right he's got that's
what he has to you know listen for a
fifteen to twenty seven-year-old who can
afford or by the way for a
ninety-year-old for any human being that
can afford what you're willing to pay
them and they want to learn sales or
they just like it you need to figure out
I actually I actually think what are the
most interesting things that are brewing
do you know that I'm I'm this is classic
me but I have an idea of starting you
know a start-up like incubator in a
retirement home you know how everything
is you know these incubate like people
with time and ideas come in all shapes
and sizes and I think we miss a lot Alan
I think you need to find 69 year old
Gertrude and 17 year old Rick and and
find people that can sell and if the ROI
and what they're selling versus what
you're paying them against your product
works that's how you scale brother you
are only in the sales business because
your product is not valuable enough does
that make sense yeah cool awesome thanks
Alan I mean look that's that's reality
that can talk to me before we go to the
next question
want to go back to the industry you know
cuz I'm really fascinating from your
perspective one of things I don't do
well either is really learned my I
learned the customer I spend a lot of
time on the customer spend very little
time on the competition so I'm
I'm pop by the way I'm pumped I'm gonna
read your book this late August cuz I'm
gonna be off and like I rarely read
anything so I'm super excited
I know castings a big player I know
Michael who else kind of readers their
head what are your summary what's been
the feedback give me give me six seven
minutes of the industry chatter who's
mad at you who likes you who agrees who
disagrees what's been the buzz the
carrot I try and tell us the story of
frenemies through characters okay
Michael Casson is a connecting character
he's the power broker in the industry
he's if there's a negotiation between a
client and a platform and an agency he
he's at that table oftentimes and he
represents all three yes and you say to
him Michael isn't that a conflict of
interest he says no conflict no interest
and and you know and one potential
client said to him Michael
why should I do why should I hire you
you you kiss everyone in the business
and why should I trust that you're gonna
protect me he said you want a good
kisser I'm your man
yeah and he is a good kisser yes he's
good at that he's a character les
Moonves as I said earlier is a character
try looking at traditional media and
some of the questions for the future
Carolyn Everson is the head of
advertising for Facebook Facebook is a
major character and a way to write about
Facebook I say which I do yes Martin
Sorrell yes who was recently left
yes started WPP 33 years ago the realize
icon like I kind of give a framework
because I know a lot of kids are
watching or people that don't know the
industry in the industry the Mad Men
stuff you have an agency you know used
to be that they would place your media
you know they would buy the ads on ABC
or a billboard and make the pictures or
videos that went into it those separated
over the last 20 years and then there's
lots of different companies but those
all consolidated under the roof of how
do you position at four or five six how
many big hole 5 big hole and four days
the they are the leading one the one
with the most revenue 21 billion is WPP
followed by a Omnicom publicist Havas
and Dentsu understood and publicist I
saw a bunch of people texted me today
it's happening I guess had
earnings and the market is down on all
the holding companies say the whole in
companies are suffering that the
presumption is that the too old too many
costs that they have to eat and that
they can't move as fast as say you can a
fan media yes and and but they're scale
right there's a lot of people that want
to work with Vayner but if you're crest
or Colgate and you want to work a veiner
you're excited about us but you know
we're established in the US but we're
emerging in the UK we're opening up
Singapore in in March but that's not
gonna mean anything to them right now
and if they need an agency and they
gotta be in South America the global
scale tends to work for these branding
right not only what are their advantages
well an advantage is data they have more
data than you do yeah and and and
increasingly the client is saying I need
more data in order to be able to target
my ads yes so it's so sad that Colgate
and Procter and Unilever don't realize
two things what that data actually is
and more importantly the fact that they
need to own the data you know and
actually is one of the interesting
things renting data from a holding
company that is dirty data for what
you're trying to achieve and more
importantly is actually commoditized cuz
everybody has the same data and the
variable is do you know how to move the
levers in real time and make the
pictures and videos the fact that the
industry believes what you just said
makes me laugh inside and just makes me
point to my wrist just a matter of time
because people don't understand what the
commodities are and what the value props
about one of the things that's happened
in the advertising business is that the
the Mad Men of Odessa Don Draper's has
decreed have lost power that's right and
the media agency has gained power yes
Hart because they supposedly have the
data well they have these you know they
have these data that they but then they
deploy they're on the exchange and the
data gets deployed against websites in
banner ad form which means the date is
worthless because nobody looks at the
banner ad ad ESP is not valuable if
nobody sees the goddamn picture but then
increasingly yes those media agencies
that have grown empowering yes is
holding yes they increasingly worried
about the Facebook's and Google who have
much better data and because but it's
you know what's so funny can and this is
a point that what
not being made and fun to talk to you
because I know how well you do your
research forget about having better data
it's because they have ad products
they're actually being consumed can I'm
telling you right now like on my
children's health Facebook has great
data a DSP could have great data we both
know you're Ken we both know you're
seven you know like we know these things
right where do you see it in a Facebook
feed you actually see it now we go fast
we don't see everything you just see it
better than you see it on a desktop
banner ad on Willie Willie calm below
the fold that's all this is just the
game of where's the attention larry page
of google once said to me when I was
doing my google book he said half the
people click on the ads and you don't
pay the advertiser doesn't pay which
very unless someone clicks on me more he
said half the people who do a search
click on the ads because they see the
ads is information yes
not as a sales pitch yes and so it
becomes more valuable good point
Google's done a very good job of being a
tollbooth if you're typing in Pepsi
they've convinced Pepsi to buy ads
against Pepsi they've done a very nice
job being a tollbooth I'm excited to see
what Alexa does to search let's go to
another question well Alexia you think
about it half the people who do a
product search do it on Amazon you know
not Google oh it's it's M wait to wait
to actual search right hey Alexa what's
WPP stock price that's just faster I
don't know this is a really interesting
moment because Thank You Alexa Alexa
stop what's interesting about that is
seven months ago
nine months ago when I asked that
question all Alexa said was sorry I
don't know every second that little
thing there's getting smarter and
smarter and smarter and and chain harder
and it changes search oh it's gonna
destroy search people don't understand
what's coming at Google better win with
the bubble there or they're in trouble
Derek Derek its Gary B you're on with
Ken Aletta Gary what's happenin
it's good say hello to Ken hey Ken hi
good morning
what are you from what do you do what's
your question - appleís Minnesota I own
a small digital marketing agency
Facebook ad Instagram agency for small
businesses society to talk guys of
course huh what coming up your asset
class is the name of our business of
course what's the call brother let's
make sure we get out there what's it all
vital traffic labs isn't it more
business I don't and love it we also
have a blog - guys on YouTube where we
document you know I following your lead
here so good man my question I just
wanted to talk about data privacy I know
for a lot of our clients it's uh it's a
concern you know people are worried
about targeting being taken away
you know household income basically
those big into collections that yeah I
get it companies have been leveraging to
me as an advertiser I look at it as a
positive because it's really going to
make competition you know more difficult
more difficult to target but in reality
you talked about like owning data I
think there's a big opportunity for
people to just advertise smarter and you
know really do a better job rather than
using these big data sets that who knows
how they even got the same so I was just
curious like what your opinion on just
like the the private book and again all
that's good of all Ken you go first I'll
go second I mean I think that one of the
one of the cultural or historical
factors that impedes Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg is Facebook has always had a
lower opinion of privacy as always felt
that we're in the business of sharing
information of communication of creating
community yes and that and that our
consumers yes are less concerned about
privacy yes that there may be some other
people yeah increasingly however because
we're learning that consumers are more
concerned about privacy in the Mark
Zuckerberg can witness him and compelled
to appear before Congress and real quick
on that because I think it's an
important point you know how people like
to say things and then do something else
do you believe it's just one man's
opinion
do you believe this conversation about
people caring about privacy is more
conversation versus what they actually
do in real life
in their behavior it's important yeah it
is
I think that clearly historically
Americans are less concerned or are less
agitated and concern about privacy than
Western Europeans that's right
witness the EU report on privacy that
have just been imposed however if you
think about what what the advertisers
say the future is targeted as that field
don't feel like ads but feel like
information
so imagine Gary you're walking down the
street you have your GPS yep we know
that you bought a sport jacket at
Barneys yep two months ago yep you're
only two blocks from Barneys yes right
if you go into Barney's now yes we'll
give you 20% off yes sir new sport jack
yes now how to scare we respond to that
tremendously well or you might see that
as a service tremendously as you say or
but some Gary's might say how do hell do
you know so much about me well they're
gonna another concern about they're
gonna know because the cats out of the
bag right I think the bigger part here
is so my big thing on this is now we
know now listen if your common sense to
American now you're not like what you
don't think when you go on the internet
like it's impossible now you know and so
the more interesting conversation comes
next this gets into a much more
interesting macro convo about how humans
work there are humans that are scared of
terrorism because it's pushed on them as
a conversation right and then there's um
you know individuals who are like hmm if
terrorism was as scary as I'm told it is
well then a car would be driving into
Times Square every single day of the
week running into 39 people because it's
fundamentally impossible I will use my
logical mind and so people make logical
and emotional decisions I want my data
to be everywhere because I want to save
time time is more valuable to me than
anything else but by Gary Lisa let's say
you're right
yeah but let's say that by the way real
quick Derek Derek real quick to things
because I don't want to please
hang but I think Ken and I are about to
go into
rabbit hole so I want to be respectful
to things brother number one if Facebook
had no targeting none zero
you know like television I write I would
tell you that it would be the best ad
product in the world because what would
happen is you would still have the
attention of the end consumer and yes we
would be guessing and it wouldn't be fun
for me to put wine ads in the feed where
people don't drink wine but guess what I
see car ads and beer ads if I watched a
commercial 90 percent of the time on
television during a sporting event and I
don't do either so the price of Facebook
ads to just get overall awareness would
still be a remarkably better deal than
90 percent of the alternatives as long
as the ads knie continues to not go in
there by the big holding companies
because they haven't figured out how to
make enough margin in there the the 97%
of Facebook's revenues come from
advertisers yeah and and those revenues
come largely from advertisers who say I
like the fact that you can target yeah
ads unfazed it's not just about today's
yeah today and so if I can't target if I
don't have the data it's ken it's cuz
everyone's wrong about the awareness on
Facebook ken the awareness Facebook does
is remarkably better than the dtc work
that's happening on facebook every
entrepreneur is laughing at every big
company in the world right now because
they're making a fortune on the
targeting capabilities on facebook to
your point what people don't realize is
the real value of Facebook right now is
top of the funnel awareness but all the
[ __ ] madmen are too artsy fartsy and
think a commercial is more special than
a facebook video but boy you Lisa you're
a guy who would who would who doesn't
like banner ads freedom isn't isn't what
you're talking about the equivalent of a
banner ad of course but can iran banner
ads for Wine Library in 1996 cuz they
got 14% click-throughs back then I don't
like anything or I don't hate anything I
like what customers are doing this
second I'd a try day trade attention
brother I day trade attention I have no
feelings for anything I can't wait to
make videos in nine years saying
Facebook's [ __ ] [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] are you guys still in
Facebook how do you not understand
AI how do you not understand VR how do
you not understand influencer marketing
on boo boo calm
I have zero emotion once you have
emotion you're vulnerable this is about
day trading attention every second of
the day
and the top of the funnel brand work at
scale to move coca-cola and BMW lives in
one place Facebook almost no one's
talking about that alright but please
you say something that's pregnant with
with questions which yes if in fact 7 to
9 years from now yes Facebook may be
disrupted yes I mean I understand
somewhere in a garage yes happy it's
Steve Jobs in the garage of Sally's in
her garage right now but what what is
the how do you how do you disrupt to a
net with network effects benefit yeah of
Facebook yeah 2.2 billion consumers what
what is the garage you would have said
you would have said the same well first
of all platform changes so right now
we're talking about visual and here hey
Alexa who's Mark Zuckerberg you know
when we start going
when these middleman when you know I
never knew marks middle name Mark
Elliott Alexa stop can you know this
when we move to a different platform all
bets off I far you know there's only two
companies I'm really bullish on Facebook
and Amazon you know when we go to voice
2.2 billion get reset you would have
said the same thing about IBM you would
have said the same thing about Microsoft
you would have said the same thing about
Google you know that you know that
actually I you feel out of all the years
of disruption from Woolworths to Walmart
from all the years you're telling me now
this is the one it's Facebook it's this
one
no so I die I have a heart I mean I
having written a yes covering the
Microsoft trial yes thousand yes and
where the just apart yes claimed and the
judge yeah the original judge you know
that they should be broken up yeah I
thought was a crazy decision cuz that's
right break him up that's right I have a
harder time with with the benefits of
network effect because you haven't spent
time on blockchain now
you haven't spent enough time on what
you just haven't spent enough time when
I watch I watch face book by Instagram
and drive people who pretension
companies that could potentially shore
up them and the government stepping back
and allowing them to do this if you want
the government to get involved good news
sometimes they I'm not saying you do
good news sometimes they do I'll tell
you right now Amazon is far far more
along in the leverage they have than
Facebook well and I noticed you left
Google off your list because you see
Amazon
I don't threat name bro my POV on Google
and Apple is it already happened to them
through the merit of actual merit of
business look I believe left on merit
Facebook and Amazon get disrupted I feel
like that happens I feel like there are
moments in time that governments like to
get involved because they get scared
I feel like Europe is more on privacy
just because it's an older version of
entitlement than America is it's just
300 years ahead of us you know they also
had the world war two and Hitler in I
get it I get it I get it but you know
look it's not stopping
nationalism across the world right so
regulating Google is not going to change
you know people's you know wiring of
thank God
slightly more love than hate and that
always is gonna play itself out Derek I
also think that your point is exactly
right brother and I'm excited for the
future your business it will be a
practitioners game it is now and you
know this even with all the data to your
point the data has made a lot of
advertisers lazy and not good
you know this Derek even if you're an
amateur you could be good at Facebook
cuz it's so under priced and so good
right admit it admit it right now
like you couldn't believe how good you
are at it at first knowing deep down in
your heart [ __ ] I don't even know
anything yet true or not yeah for for a
local or local business to just take a
bad at running Facebook ads they could
do some serious damage without really
knowing much at all and all of a sudden
you're the darling of the ice cancer yep
exactly but when it comes like a
national campaign or you know what you
talked about acting Amazon or getting
people to the doing sales on their own
e-commerce or Shopify like that's where
it could you know more technical and
we're you know leveraging data yes but
let me tell you as somebody who lived
through early internet and then lived
through early Google AdWords the C
players are still making way too much
money on Facebook that means the biggest
companies in the world are not pouring
the proper amount of money in their
Derek your game your game with Facebook
is to continue to hope that the
companies that Ken wrote about in
frenemies continue to think that they
can make more margin on their own DSP
and programmatic and on television
because as long as they keep doing the
wrong thing for the biggest clients in
the world you and I will continue to eat
in their selfishness thank you you got a
man take care I can't oh [ __ ] sorry
Derek
ken I really believed that last
statement I I'm very you know I I'm not
Mother Teresa I I
I put legacy over currency so that
drives my actions and my ambitions of
buying brands just happened to by
accident align my interests better with
my clients that piqued my clients
getting better services from Vayner is
absolutely a collateral from my selfish
ambition but it is playing out no I mean
listen if they were smarter and more
attuned to the reality what's happening
they would fear you more than they do
you mean the holding companies of course
but there but them and the clients are
it has nothing to do with smart and you
know this you learn this a long time ago
when you're in 71 year old executive and
you're leaving in 24 months and you've
worked your ass off and you want to buy
three villas in a yacht
you're saying one thing I'm gonna do
nothing to disrupt to disrupt the stock
price so that when I leave I can strike
and there's no way I'm gonna vaynermedia
doesn't make money
my poor CFO wants to punch me in the
face every day because I'm investing in
voice and an AI and machine learning and
influencer and Singapore he's okay let's
make a little bit I'm like no this is
our time we're the legacy companies the
holding companies say we'll buy Gary
that's right company and what they don't
we Gary says I won't sell to you and and
there's something else about Gary that's
funny
and I don't know where this chip came
from maybe I was short when I was a kid
I was an immigrant there's a million
reasons I can come up with it
it's not about me I'm gonna do great so
Vayner is gonna be a two billion dollar
company peanuts it's that I'm obsessed
with inspiring Derrick and Sally to stay
independent and then [ __ ] gets real
interesting Gary's gonna do a nice
little job at Vayner and do a couple
billion Gary inspiring an entire
generation to tell the holding companies
to go [ __ ] themselves cuz they actually
make more money with staying independent
in the long term that's a big [ __ ]
problem and you're right if they really
really really really knew what I was up
to because usually they rely on greed
not legacy and when you get a character
that comes along that cares about legacy
and knows how to do coms better than
anybody else your industry you should
find for you
please viewers what you mean by legacy
for me reputation yeah rapid current
reputation that only grow you know I
want to be the reverse of Christopher
Columbus I mean that I I Know Who I am I
know how I roll I like that here's that
what I like about the way I roll that I
want to inspire other people to roll I
love that the people that know me the
best like me and admire me the best I
don't mind people that see me cursing on
stage saying he's a charlatan I have
empathy I understand why they would go
there I know what I look like as a cover
but I know I like to be have a good
reputation with the people that know
right and then I like that it will grow
in respect as it looks back upon to
really under what I'm really doing with
15 year olds on Instagram right now and
the propaganda of kindness and gratitude
and empathy and being the bigger person
the things that I'm teaching to a
generation of alpha males right now I
will never reap the benefits of that
work today but I think my grandkids are
gonna be really proud when people chat
about it once people can dissect it and
I have a great benefit that Muhammad Ali
and others didn't have it's all being
documented and you know I've very big
ambition and I see documented what's
that were documented I film the whole
goddamn life you know like it's it's a
very it's a very big ambition I'm up for
the challenge but I will say this it is
all built on the thing that you've
covered your entire career which is this
amazing audacity
people doing the wrong thing for
short-term economics at the expense of
their legacy I can't wait you know it's
easy to talk about this year you
mentioned earlier that I came to you
through Beth CompStat that's right at GE
and I said to Beth I said Beth who
should I talk to who is a disruptor in
in the we said Gary Vaynerchuk and
vaynermedia and and in fact you are one
of the people I profile as the disruptor
and the other is Bob Greenberg at r/ga
who basically says that the ad agency is
the dinosaurs that's right it has to we
have to redefine yourself in another way
I love you guys I spent time with in the
book as juxtaposed swp peas and the
others can I appreciate you being here
my pleasure Ken on the show we guest
gets to ask the question of the day and
you know as a research man I don't mind
where you go with this maybe you already
know the next thing you want to write
maybe there's something that you're just
curious about you've got a ton of
entrepreneurs skewing under 40 pretty
aggressively
you know what question of the day do you
have for them doesn't have to stay in
the context of our talk even because I
know your brains always working on the
next thing potentially or maybe just
don't know how the Mets are gonna finish
their season I don't care where you go
with it
I'm not gonna ask you how you're gonna
buy the New York Jets you're asking them
and my 13th book I would like to be a
biography and I am wrestling with hmm
who is a great biography subject and so
all ideas are welcomed I love that
you've never done that I've done
profiles
I know I know York I know yours I know
but i-i've never I'd like to exercise
another muscle by writing a Bible I love
it but I don't want to do historical
biography because I like to interview
people and I can't have you dead people
I love it
Ken thanks for being on the show you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]